what's going on guys this is rob and
it's like 10-something at night so I
can't be too loud you know I don't want
to disturb the neighbors or anything
like that so bear with me this video is
going to be kind of quiet but I wanted
to I wanted to do like a nine hundred
thousand subscribers celebration kind of
not really I feel like doing at nine
hundred thousand subscribers celebration
is like coming along and saying hey
we're celebrating like our 40 7520 3rd
subscriber because whatever like she's
like an arbitrary number and like you
celebrate like particular milestones
100,000 subs half a million subs a
million subs and I'm really excited for
for when we cross the million subs
fingers crossed hopefully we reach that
milestone I'm really excited for that I
feel like it's been an incredible
journey with you guys to get to this
point and that's what I want to talk
about here because there's really this
video is just an excuse for me to be
able to tell this story is really all it
is is just a reason for me to be able to
tell this so as most of you guys know I
just got back from emerald city comicon
and and I love going to come about
conventions because it gives me a chance
to to like meet you guys you know and I
think that's one of the coolest things
is it's one thing when I'm making videos
and i'm uploading them and you guys are
like this is a cool video rob you know I
see your comments it's another when you
guys like walk up to me and you're like
hey Rob I'm a huge fan and it's like
here's the video series that you did
that I enjoy the most nine times out of
10 it's like Civil War Infinity Gauntlet
the Incredible Hulk or like I don't know
something else like jonathan hickman's
Fantastic Four is usually like one of
those four things it's almost always
Civil War but it's one of those four
things or at least it's usually like
Civil War got me into your channel or
something on those lines but and this
particular instance but I want to say
this guy's name is Justin I apologize
have fun if I have the wrong man but
we're going to call you Justin everybody
in the chant everyone in the comments
called a schedule but but in this
particular instance it with a little bit
different so um when we were at emerald
city comicon we had a table set up for
the weekly poll of the podcast zone and
the idea was to really keep everybody
therefore he'd roll there for at least
four hours of every day I mean that was
like the minimum but we don't really do
minimums we just do it as often as we
can
and so we pretty much had people there
like like the whole day you know I mean
it was like you know from from the time
we got there to the time we left there
were always people at the table now we
would cycle folks out just so that
everybody would have time to go to the
con so like you know then he would go
down to the con floor for a little while
then I would go and or myself and Benny
would go or whatever the case may be but
we would rotate people out so everybody
got a chance to see what was going on
but um I was downstairs vaping and I got
a text from Benny as I was on my way up
and Benny was like hey man you need to
come back here there's a fan that's
trying to see you and I said okay cool
so I get up there and this do Justin had
been trying to catch me like three or
four times and had missed me each time
that he stopped by and I feel terrible I
was like man I keep missing the sky you
know I didn't realize he was trying to
catch google for it and so um he finally
you know catches me is like hey man I'm
a huge fan and that this is this is
probably gonna be well my favorite
stories ever when it when it comes to
cons but he's like hey man I'm a huge
fan and so he was like you kept talking
about how awesome this story was and so
I bought it and so he he reaches into
his backpack he was carrying around this
black backpack and he reaches into his
backpack and he pulls out the trade for
Marvel Knights the century and we
started running over what we know what
we thought our favorite moments were and
the story and I told of my favorite
moment from Marvel Knights a century was
when it was like the calm before the
storm ride like like the people had
figured out who the void was there were
a lot of really cool moments you know
early on the sort of rubber rentals went
around a bit of different people like
Reed Richards and Reed Richards like I
can't remember who you are but I'm not
supposed to remember like he started
picking things up and he remembered like
the golden unicorn and so on is so poor
i think i might remaster that video
because i loved i love that story so
much and you know there's this moment at
the end near the end where the void is
showing up and The Incredible Hulk looks
at Robert Reynolds and says Hulk is
scared and Robert Reynolds replies it
says so am i or so many one was one but
it's like this beautiful moment because
it was like Robert Reynolds was like one
of the only people in the incredible
whole considered a real friend and so it
was like this beautiful moment between
these two like powerhouse characters um
but you know I was like yeah I mean I
salida form because he asked me to sign
a form and everything and then
him myself and Sal got it like this huge
discussion i like the marble cosmology
and annihilation and so on and so forth
when we pulled out this these post-it
notes he had and he's posted notes were
a reading order for coming books for
first stories that he wanted to check
out stories and people were suggesting
and it was everything from Marvel DC
Valiant Comics the whole nine yards of
it was it was all over the place and the
idea was okay you know like let's go
through this list let's see what you
have you know and see if we can improve
on it well the more I was talking to him
the more excited he was getting and so I
looked at salad I was like hey Sal can
you keep an eye on the table for a while
he's like yeah sure so I told the two gs
sounds like what's good out there so we
got on service to the con for now for a
lot of the guys who have never been to a
comic book convention when it comes to
bind comic books nine times out of 10
it's just publishers who show up on the
conf or not publishers distributors who
show up on the con floor they've got
long boxes full of inventory they just
can't sell they just you know throw them
in each bargain bins a dollar each you
go in by what you want then you just
kind of take off leaving get some great
deals that way like you can buy the
whole fatal attraction story for like
ten bucks which is it beats the hell out
of the trade it in terms of just in
terms of getting a good deal on the on
the product that you're buying but um
but the factory make sure that you know
as we were going through we were we were
trying to find these trade sellers and
you'll find him every once in a while
you'll find a whole section dedicated to
like selling trades on the business
different things like that and so we
found we found one and as we were going
through these different trades he was
like hey man like just so you know I
don't really have that much to spend I
have like you know personal things that
I need to take care of and I was like
nah dude this is on me all right we
spent three hundred and fifty dollars on
each I got him everything I was like hey
man are you a fan of the flash and he's
like yeah so I got him all of Geoff
Johns run of the flash I got him flash
rebirth when Barry Allen first came back
after final crisis I got him a flash
point and then I got him a DC rebirth of
flash what was it lightning strike twice
I think the first volume I mean we got
all star superman we got new x-men here
comes tomorrow
we got infinity war I want to say that
we got uh I want to say that we got
superior iron man but i'm not going to
swear to that we got a bunch of superior
spider-man stuff I think I mean I loaded
this dude up and the whole time he's
freaking out like the whole time he's
just like you don't know what to say I
don't know what to say and I was like
dude you're cool man don't worry about I
was like this is ugly you spent all day
waiting to see me the least I can do is
like help you trim down your wish list
because here's the cool thing is because
if I if I go to him and I say hey man
here's like here's like 30 trains on
your on your list then that means that
that's money that that he is no money
that he can now spend like beefing up
that he can get stories you know to
complement the ones you already have now
the biggest issue was that when it comes
to like trade dealers when it comes to
comic book conventions again they're
just getting rid of inventory they can't
sell and so very rarely can you find
like all the trades for a whole run
right i mean you wouldn't be able to go
there and find like all of superior
spider-man if you're lucky you might but
you usually don't usually find like you
know volumes one and then volumes you
know three and four or something like
that you're you're just missing one it's
like this thing where you pull your hair
out of your head and you try to jump
around from trade seller the trade Sela
you know trying to finish out trying to
complete the whole thing but sometimes
you just can't but um me I got him what
I could I was like look man I'm sorry we
can't get you like the whole run asleep
he's like dogs cool man this is way more
than I and it was awesome like his this
backpack was killing him by the time we
got back so so we get back upstairs and
I'm like yeah man like that should keep
bashing you know 30 trays or so like you
should be you should be kind of for a
while like you'll be able to read for a
while but it was just it was it was it
was cool because for me and I think for
most youtubers for me it's almost like
being Santa Claus right you know I mean
it's almost like being being Santa Claus
um I don't mean to toot my own horn i
love jimmy johns I want me to toot my
own horn but I think that there are a
lot of fans that I have out there who
are like man I really wish I could just
meet Rob
and there are times when I come across a
fan who is just so enamored with the
idea of just like I love your channel I
can't believe I'm meeting you who's just
so swept up and they get so emotional
that I can't help but get emotional too
then it's just like I mean I don't cry
but it's just like yeah man like this
guy's excited and I get excited and
she's like yeah man we're excited
together like I don't know why I'm
excited but worse and it's really cool
because I get to meet you guys and
that's the coolest thing like as excited
as you guys would get to meet me as
excited as a lot of the guys are being
you know to say man I get to meet Rob
like it's as exciting for me to meet you
because it's just like because I mean I
ask you guys questions like what got you
out of my channel and and you know what
do you love the most about it it's just
it's really cool to get to know you guys
and every once in a while I like to do
something for Sam I like to kind of just
sit up and down and say hey look I can't
do this all the time but you're the
lucky winner today you know I like I
like being able to do that because I
think it helps me feel like I can
connect better with you guys it helps me
feel like because that I'm giving back
you know to a fan base that has given me
so much and so so here's what we're
gonna do I'm gonna go ahead and out
Susan we're going to do um I'm kind of
the process of like getting rid of a lot
of the trades that i have just because
of the fact that I get on my
comicsdigital II now and like I go into
comiXology and get all myself or I use
Marvel unlimited you know if a comic
book is really really old I usually have
to use bc for everything because DC
doesn't have a version of Marvel
unlimited but with all my comics
existing digitally now there really
isn't a place for me to sit down and to
say okay you know i'm going to go
through the process of like collecting
trades and so a lot of the trades that i
have i don't really read anymore and so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to you
know start giving away trades I think I
think we're out we're going to give
gifts and trades away and i have i have
a lot of them i mean i have all kinds of
trades for all kinds of different things
so i think we're gonna go ahead and give
a bunch of those out i'm not sure how
we're going to do it leave a comment
down below and suggest how you think it
is that we should do that but you know I
think we're gonna do some some giveaways
and because I think it's important to
give back I think it's important to sit
down and to say hey look you know
instead of just taking and taking them
taking me I give you guys Compton
that's cool that's a give and take thing
you know I upload content that i enjoy i
read through your comments if you guys
post suggestions and it's a story that i
enjoy i'll make a video on it you know
if it's story that i don't enjoy well i
will really make a video on it but you
know it's kind of this give-and-take
between what you guys asked for and what
I were you know put up on my channel and
trying to provide a bounce but that's
kind of like then the nature of YouTube
right I mean if that's the core
principle of YouTube is given cake I
feel like in an instance of giving
something back it's not just be giving
you guys content it's a way of saying
thanks and so I think I'm think we're
gonna do that but I just want to share
that story with you guys I thought it
was something that was really cool and I
thought it was really interesting and I
just it makes me good or make sure makes
me too good god that sounds it sounds
terrible it makes me feel good to know
that I was able to make a fan's day like
that you know that that that guy is
going to say like I went on a shopping
spree with commas to explain and he was
like a cool guy and we had a great time
together and I just don't like that all
the time I don't buy people at summit
raids but like there was one instance
where we went to I went to baltimore
comic-con there was a couple of fans
that I ran into and I was waiting on
Vinny and everybody's show up so we just
went got ice cream off so you guys want
ice cream and they're like yeah so we
were like we just walk around a con eat
ice cream and it was amazing yeah I love
I love hanging out with you guys I love
spending time with you guys you know
getting to know you guys and in that
kind of thing you know cuz you guys you
guys are the Rob core you're my fam be
better you I just want to share that and
yeah leave a comment down below let me
know how you think we should do this
giveaway because I'm kind of curious as
to what ideas you guys come up with and
yeah I will catch you all later please
maybe maybe possibly i can't stop the
video I can't turn it up why I want to
turn off